the area is not exactly hip but it's
home to a michelin-starred restaurant
noble haunt and schmutz ik one of
Britain's most fashionable places to eat
it opened in 2015 with a start-up
capital of five hundred sixty thousand
euros and a chef who had already made a
name for himself
Misha Schaffer and his team cook up a
ten-course meal every day this is orders
via product URLs we only use products
from the area around Berlin and of
course we only take the best ingredients
and when I serve these spring onions
today I'll marinate them first in a
little butter and yogurt way but they're
basically just taste of spring onions
the full ten course meal costs about 100
euros the chef really means it when he
says he only uses regional product
there's no olive oil no pepper and no
lemon I'm the home of the super design
we're interested in finding the taste of
this region if you come here from Sao
Paulo or San Francisco or Sydney or
Beijing you want to know what's the
authentic cuisine of Berlin or the
region is it just dona kebabs sausage
with curry ketchup and pork knuckle or
is there more to it when when I spine or
I could start lean on me of course there
is more but even in the realm of fast
food more and more regional and organic
products are being used all the capito
sells only locally sourced meat
virtually the entire animal is used
she sells cuts of meat fillets and
steaks everything else lands in the
mincer and then on the grill one of her
burgers costs about 5 euros
Piku says it's not a recipe for getting
rich but she loves her work other than
supply is it's not really I want to know
where the food that I eat comes from and
that's difficult in Berlin because it's
such a huge City
that's why organic food has become so
much more popular because at least then
customers know it can't be too bad does
my Venus inspires mr. schlimmer for
years now consumers have been more
selective about what they eat more and
more people want to know where their
food comes from for them price is not
the only issue when they decide what
food to buy fake field office baba does
happen a cop side hours have your head
tells you to pay more attention and your
stomach does too the food tastes good
it's also a very human thing
I don't want food from far away I want
to be closer to whoever's producing my
food less Misha and Mia as this survived
back from you you could hardly get any
closer to the producer of your food than
in this restaurant here you can see your
salad growing behind the counter these
ones are for weeks in the system so they
are ready to be consumed
it's called vertical farming and can be
used for growing produce in a skyscraper
or even a spaceship the future is
actually now if you want fresh produce
not everyone ever Vulcan I don't have a
Vulcan in my partner so this is a way to
fresh vegetables inside their place this
farming method uses no pesticides and
surprisingly little electricity
investors provided two hundred thousand
euros startup capital this diner is the
first of its kind in the world it's
called the good bank in satsang is Asus
can't feel a good our dream is that
there'll be lots of good banks it will
open a flagship store where guests can
experience good bank farming and our
amazing dishes on a larger scale and
also that will continue expanding if the
experts
for now they're growing butter head and
oak leaf lettuce and baby kale it's
harvested as needed so there's no waste
and diners get a salad that's as fresh
as can be